it's a long man to shoot over a seven
foot four wingspan use Mitchell able to
slip inside cognizant of that situation
Mitchell sets up with a three point look
and not [ __ ] the buffalo sausages has
not gone down yet so the thumbs Burke's
in a game here's Mitchell boy just a
smooth shooting spree got those legs at
home go try to lay it up on the nerve
tooth like that Mitchell foul on the
three and he'll be on the line looking
for the Rubio steps in gets the steal up
ahead to Mitchell
[Applause]
catch it super Mitchell boy he is locked
in here on this Friday night he's got a
teen who's still trying to do his best
to open to the floor he's got five
assistant I laughter that speed as
Mitchell gets and just consider the
injuries as Mitchell finds himself free
again on the Miss he'll set up give it
another try
like staffers are traditionally ill
minutes we've heard a little bit
learning the game Mitchell impressively
just come off like he's being a lunatic
just ask the Clippers is the Jazz
probably had as much to do with the
disassembling of the Clippers I'm a slow
star but he's got sixteen now Mitchell
able to get topped accent
right now I think it's going to take a
straitjacket let's throw down
Donovan Mitchell
[Applause]